nous sommes sur ce plateau avec régis le
sommier grand reporter rt france régis
dans ce contexte en s'aggravant enfin
donc qui déplore la réponse de
washington mais estime quand même que ça
pourrait être le début d'une
conversation sérieuse il ya le pharma
dormandy de l'autre côté macro qui
rencontre par téléphone il s'entretient
par téléphone avec les numéros poutine
demain que peut-on espérer
aujourd'hui à ce stade comme compromis
il ne fallait pas espérer que d'abord
que là la réponse américaine
comme on donne une réponse en tout cas
ferme et définitif sur la question de
l'otan parce que dans une crise comme ça
les détails sont très importants et les
mots sont très importants et dans la
dans une surenchère verbale on est dans
une crise qui est très avancé
diplomatiquement et il fallait pas que
les états unis aient l'air de capituler
mais ce qui est intéressant quand même
et sergueï lavrov l'a souligné c'est les
autres points justement à même si le
comment la pièce centrale et là là là
qu'on la pièce maîtresse finalement de
cette négociation n'a pas été honorée
enfin en tout cas les américains non non
absolument pas céder sur la question de
l'otan donc là il ya quand même des
choses intéressantes il ya encore des
round de discussions qui vont se
produire ce qui reste quand même tout de
même très inquiétant c'est l'activité
militaire les déplacements de soldats le
fait que beaucoup de pays de l'otan le
danemark l'espagne et ses commensaux
s'ils envoient des troupes ou renvoie
pas des trous et on voit des du matériel
écueil est toute une agitation qui se
fait et également des manoeuvres
militaires et des marges manoeuvres
maritimes de l'otan trois porte-avions
méditerranéen italien le sbc straumann
pour les états unis et en prévision le
charles de gaulle donc on est voilà on
est de toujours dans une cette forme de
prb où chacun s'agite et montrent qu'il
est sérieux ce qui est plus aussi très
embêtant moi je trouve dans ce genre de
crise si cette crise débouché sur une
guerre ce qui est quand même très
dommageable c'est de se rendre compte
lui un certain nombre d'individus
je parle dans notamment qu'il s'agit
dans les médias pour justement appelée
presqu'à la guerre bon moi ça me navre
parce que je parle de la plupart des
grands médias américains qui n'ont pas
appris leurs leçons et j'appelle ça une
petite musique vous savez c'est cette
petite musique qu'on rappelle à chaque
fois en disant attention comme si la
guerre à les solutionner quelque chose
on l'a vu avec l'afghanistan on l'a vu
avec l'irak on l'a vu encore avec la
libye souvenez vous c'est toujours les
mêmes c'est toujours le même la même
tonalité
médias il ya beaucoup de républicains y
compris réponse et aux états unis à
cette espèce d'unanimisme comme si on
n'avait rien appris de la guerre
précédente et du désastre que ces
guerres ont provoqué que l'ukraine
devienne un champ de bataille c'est un
désastre en soi et là on a quand même
des gens qui continuent malgré tout il
ya eu l'exemple irakien des pays qui ont
été anéantis souvenez-vous delà de la
limite
bien sûr sur la base d'un mensonge et
puis sur la libye moi je j'ai été
frappée il ya un an un peu plus d'un an
je me suis rendu à bengazi j'ai vu un
pays qui il n'y a plus rien donc
qu'est-ce que ces interventions
occidentales qui était censé amener la
démocratie qui était censé contrer une
urgence takuya vais kadhafi qui allait
massacrer son peuple avant c'était
saddam hussein qui allait envoyer des
missiles ou avec des armes de
destruction massive et et finalement on
se retrouve dans un moyen-orient qu'on a
mis à feu et à sang est ce qu'on a envie
aussi que l'asie centrale de vienne
un champ de ruines voilà alors il ya la
chine dans ton en temps vous parler
aujourd'hui plus que jamais à la
diplomatie chinoise qui défend les
préoccupations raisonnable de la russie
concernant sa sécurité appelle également
toutes les parties au calme et à
l'instant à washington qui appelle
également pékin a utilisé je cite son
influence sur moscou pour éviter une
invasion de l'ukraine tient à la chine
qui il y rentre dans le jeu elle aussi
dans ce dossier ukrainien oui évidemment
il ya un positionnement et la chine voit
peut-être aussi une opportunité une
aubaine d'être peut-être le dealbreaker
dans cette histoire en tout cas on sait
que la chine est très inquiète de part
justement là là là comment le le nouveau
focus américain sur la zone indo
pacifique le retrait d'afghanistan en
était d'ailleurs un d un des premiers
développements c'est à dire pour se
concentrer sur l'extrême orient et sur
ce que les américains appellent le
finalement la menace chinoise notamment
avec la le comment le
l'augmentation considérable des
dernières années du potentiel militaire
notamment de la marine chinoise qui est
un des indes et que l'un des points clés
qui inquiète le plus est américain mais
là on a voilà on a le problème de cette
crise aussi c'est de l'eau risque de
pousser et les on voit bien que les
américains cet appel ou chinois est
aussi comme plein de sous-entendus parce
que le risque c'est de pousser la russie
justement dans le camp de machines et là
ça devient beaucoup plus compliqué vous
avez un pays qui est en phase de devenir
la première économie du monde la russie
qui a largement redressé la tête qui a
un potentiel militaire est une des zones
d'influencé qu'ils la retrouvent qu'elle
a retrouvée dans le monde bah oui les
etats-unis ne peuvent plus composer ne
peuvent plus ce n'est plus la vraie ce
qui est très intéressant dans cette
crise aussi c'est le fait que les états
unis ne sont plus le super gendarme du
monde il le sable ils ne veulent plus
l'être mais la voilà il se retrouve avec
une canne cry 2 avec une crise avec la
russie comme il en avait l'habitude mais
ce n'est plus la plus grande superficie
à une super puissance c'est un pays qui
a beaucoup de problèmes c'est un pays
dont le président a beaucoup de
problèmes
problème inter intérieur qui n'arrivent
pas à faire passer ses réformes et on
sent une certaine fébrilité de la part
des américains dans cette crise nous
peut-être l'idée de cette surenchère le
risque encore aussi j'y terminerai par
ça c'est ses pattes angle avait la
volonté réelle d'aller en guerre de la
part des uns et des autres c'est le
faire qu'un incident regardez ce matin
il ya cinq que cinq soldats comment
ukrainiens qui ont été abattus par un un
nu craignent un donc un on ne connaît
pas encore tous levés modalités mais
tout de suite cinq soldats ont été tués
qu'est ce que c'est par paf et tout le
monde commence à être voilà et deux
d'une petite crise comme ça ou d'un
noeud une petite escarmouche peu dégoûté
peut se terminer en une guerre ouverte
alors le fameux gazoduc nord stream 2 1
devient un enjeu dans cette affaire
à l'instant au cil à cil a réussi envahi
le crem le gazoduc nord stream ii ne
sera pas activée assure washington même
son de cloche à berlin on imagine
peut-être qu emmanuel macron va dire la
même chose demain à vladimir poutine
c'est une messe est devenu une monnaie
des changes ce gazoduc déjà il le nord
stream était lui activé on sait très
bien que les allemands sont dépendants
du gaz nous aussi pour une part mais ils
sont aussi dépendants des hydrocarbures
russes et également du charbon donc
l'économie allemande était fortement
orientée vers justement les
hydrocarbures de la russie indirectement
nous aussi on sait aussi que les russes
à 11,7 ses immenses réserves de gaz
alors que nous on en a quasiment plus en
europe en ce qu'il y avait comme en
angleterre ou même au danemark on est
complètement tari aujourd'hui donc on
est dépendant de ce gaz on est dépendant
du gaz aussi vendu des pays du maghreb
mais mais principalement voilà il y à
7,7 en jeu et on est d'où je pense ça
peut expliquer la prudence allemande
mais effectivement l'ouverture d'un du
second pipeline est conditionnée à
beaucoup de choses et il devient central
dans cette crise et ça pourrait aussi
une manière pour les choses se calmeront
bas peut-être on l'espère
peut-être que voilà il y aura une
solution à ce niveau là merci beaucoup
régissent le souvenir à rapporter votre
décryptage aidants